all right
team black
all right let's go with knight f6
and
go with e6
nimzo
yes
should be five
following game
uh
what games am i following
i should know
i should know about that
okay
m11
most recent so what about h6 here
um
h6
and
yeah let's throw a question that bishop
what's he gonna do
up take my knight what's the scoop
i'm trying to gather more information
just like um
that a3 move
seeing a similarity between the a3 move
and that game 11 in this h6 move
similar thought process just ran through
my mind there
was that redundant thought process mind
c5 strike at the center queen here
give that a try
try and exploit these dark squares queen
a5 does also allow for 94 moves
piling up on this guy
hmm
all right let's go
heavy fire
more fire
uh i've played this before i don't know
if i really got anything great out of it
though
this queen here
actually if the rook plays here i could
grab this pawn
okay
now what
knight e4
94 rook here and i can't take the pawn
because i'm dropping this but if 94
queen takes then i could take here
maybe i should take here first
and then play my knight here
um
let's see
i really don't know what to do
you take here and then knight here
i'm doing this because if i do this
right away rook here
if i take and then there's a recapture
my bishop has to go here i don't know if
i would really want to do that
me take here first
opens up this rank for my queen my
bishop has
a possibility to retreat
and
hmm
what's the story with this in-between
move
huh
pawn takes
threatening pawn takes discovery check
pawn takes bishop takes bishop takes
i'm going to go for that
these are going to be double isolated
material is going to be balanced and i
want a knight on this c5 square
this is the plan
knight a6 to c5 king e7 d6 bishop d7
rook c8
pile up on this pawn eventually
what do you do
with these
these weaknesses i think it's best to
make sure the queens are off the board
if there is going to be a structural
weakness
um
well it's one of the two flip a coin i
guess
but i think it's a queen takes bishop
here
what else is there queen takes pawn
takes white's in check or did they do
they log off no
they're just chewing on that one
so now knight here c5 is where it
belongs isolated puns
knight c5 no need to castle this is
perfect
however you know what i'm not going to
move my knight here just yet
because i think there might be knight d4
to this square although no i could still
do that
if yeah let's let's get here right now
if my knight is challenged with knight
b3 i'll come to a4 avoid the knight
exchange i have homes on these two
squares something i've referenced
i believe in a couple games
you know my recent analysis
videos
or reviews or whatever you want to call
them anyhow the videos
about isolated ponds and how there could
be homes for pieces and those squares on
those on the same file
as isolated pawns so
these squares
this square
bishop out my knight is watching over b7
this rook here so that my king
if it really needs to come back here it
could
let's get right here
if i need to defend this pawn i could
play here
i can also play my rook up and then over
like this
now let me do this
knight right here is going to be played
avoid the knight exchange
pile up on this guy he's soon to fall
and right now knight takes pawn is
threatened
okay so now there's absolutely no worry
of this pawn right now
just follow up this bishop can't go
anywhere
i think i do this this night just kick
it away first
maybe i could just weasel my bishop
around
c6 b7 a6 or is there something more
direct
uh there might be something more direct
like e5 bishop here
yeah i'm liking that better because it
rules out any more uh knight d4 moves in
fact the configuration of these pawns
stopped the knights forward advance
forward advance that's another redundant
one
okay wait no i'm just getting this pawn
now no i'm getting a fork that rook came
there for a reason it was forgotten
about
so less than 30 time issue as well
um
uh this is a full rook now
okay
good game
choco me
let me let me back up
let's see interesting middle game here
now
you back up
i play here
you do that i do this
you do that
i think um this is what's leading to
problems trying to insert the in-between
move i think
it's a
an uphill battle now
because of how i continued and
you end up with these double isolated
pawns structural
a structure to avoid
so
an adjustment is just the immediate
recapture i'm sure certainly something
you were uh thinking about at this point
and i think it is best
because of how i could have continued
and how i did end up
continuing so just the pawn recapture
and then
um
follow it moves i guess uh the bishop to
d3
is better than the e2 square and
bringing your knight out to f3
and we kind of just go from there right
uh so
yeah i think that this is where there
was the slip up
just taking the knight right now instead
of just the recapture with the pawn
so a simple adjustment to go with the
it's not really working out bishop takes
night there but okay
uh good game let me close
oh okay my opponent's throwing something
at me saying that they were afraid of
the knight adding pressure
yeah i think you could i think you could
deal with it
like if takes here i see i see it there
okay i see what uh they're getting at
there
so if takes here i guess there was some
worry of like g5 knight e4 stuff
takes if g5 bishop back knight e4
you come over with the rook
i don't have this queen takes pawn move
because my knight would be hanging and
there's not really more pressure i could
be placing on the knight it's just these
three but you have your queen pawn and
rook you'd have three defenders
so okay
all right let me close out
thanks uh thanks for the game i do mean
that because i'm
i'm improving as well openings are
definitely my weakest point and there's
things i could be uh certainly taking
away even though these are
quicker games
so all right very cool